hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american mind-blowing horror and
mystery movie called the skeleton key
this movie has an unpredictable plot
twist watch till the end to find out the
movie starts by showing a woman named
caroline ellis
she works as a nurse in a hospital
currently she has no family because her
mother left her when she was a child
while his father died one year ago
at one time there is a patient who dies
in the hospital
she cannot bear to see the patient he
has treated die
therefore she decides to quit her job
on her way home she reads a job
application as a caretaker of an
isolated plantation house in terrebonne
parish louisiana with a salary of one
thousand dollars per week
for that reason she is interested to
work there
later she meets her best friend named
jill at a bar and tells her about the
job
jill is worried about her because the
area is scary and there are many
mystical stories about the area but
caroline still ignores it the next day
she goes to the location listed in the
newspaper
when she gets there she's greeted by a
man named luke he then invites her to
meet his masters benjamin and violet she
is assigned to take care of benjamin who
is mostly paralyzed by an apparent
stroke
violet forbids her to take care of the
house because the house is very big
in the end she accepts the position to
work at the house
soon she starts to get her things and
says goodbye to jill
thus she promises to return to the city
often and visits her friend
on the way she stops by a gas station to
buy gas
however the place is very messy
strangely there is also a line of brick
dust outside the shop without any
suspicion she immediately pays for the
gas and goes to violet's house
there violet explains everything about
the house starting from the location of
the living room and dining room the
history of the house and also the
medicine to be given to benjamin when
she looks at a photo of two children
suddenly a mysterious photo appears on
the back which red papa justify and mama
cecile
violet explains that in the house there
are many rooms with different keys
therefore she gives caroline a key that
can open all the rooms in the house
as she walks around the house she is
confused because there is no mirror at
all in the house
violet immediately tells her by saying
that they don't need a mirror anymore
because they are already old
since then caroline has been doing her
job to take care of benjamin
every day she bathes him and she takes
him outside to get some fresh air
he cannot speak at all even moving is
very difficult for him
while they are in the garden violet
tells caroline to get some seeds from
the attic
so she rushes to the attic straight away
and she sees a mysterious door that
cannot be opened with her key she has
tried to insert the key many times but
her efforts are in vain
she returns to the garden to give the
seeds to violet and asks her about the
room that cannot be opened earlier
violet explains that the room could not
be open since they bought the house
as a result caroline is curious about
the strange room
when she falls asleep she accidentally
hears a noise from benjamin's room then
she checks his room and finds that he
has disappeared from the bed
she is confused considering benjamin is
in a stroke condition and unable to walk
she panics that something bad would
happen to him when she looks out the
window it turns out that benjamin is
trying to escape from the house
not long after that he falls from the
roof tile
she immediately asks violet for help who
is sleeping in her room
violet tells her to get a wheelchair as
she returns to benjamin's room she finds
benjamin's bed sheet which read help me
quickly she puts the sheets in her
cupboard and leaves the house to help
violet in the morning luke comes to the
house and declares himself to take care
of benjamin's family will
at the same time caroline wants to show
him the bed sheet that she found last
night when the sheet is opened the
writing is gone she then becomes puzzled
and thinks that she was hallucinating
because she was over panicked luke gives
her his business card just in case she
wants to meet him later
feeling strange she goes to the attic to
investigate the mysterious door when
using a hair clip it turns out that
something is blocking the entry of the
keyhole in the end she manages to open
the door and go straight into it she
discovers a secret room filled with
ritual paraphernalia she takes a
phonograph record conjure of sacrifice
violet suddenly comes there causing her
to break an item but then she manages to
escape
she decides to go to jill's house and
listens to the recording the recording
recites a hudu ritual
after hearing it she invites jill to go
to the club there she tells jill about
the room that she has found before
jill then explains that the room is a
hoodoo room
hoodoo is a magic used in ancient times
to convince caroline she tells her to
visit a hidden hoodoo shop in a nearby
laundromat
because they do not believe in mystical
things they agree to return to their
respective places
as a result caroline quietly puts all
the mirrors in violet's house
later violet is surprised and
immediately scolds her then caroline
confronts violet who reveals that the
room used to belong to two
african-american servants who were
employed at the house 90 years before
the servants mama cecile and papa
justify were renowned hoodoo
practitioners they were lynched after
conducting a ritual with the owner's two
children named martin and grace
after the incident violet and benjamin
later bought the house
violet tells caroline that they keep no
mirrors in the house because they see
reflections of cecile and justifying
them
the hudu followers believe that placing
brick dust around the house will protect
them from the bad person who uses hudu
magic caroline finally surmises that
benjamin's stroke was caused by hudu but
she believes that his paralytic state is
a nisbo effect induced by his own belief
rather than something supernatural
feeling unsatisfied she visits the
hidden hoodoo shop
there the hudu woman gives her tools and
instructions to cure benjamin after
getting the tools along with the new
information she goes back to the house
then she conducts the ritual and
surprisingly benjamin regains some
ability to move and speak
he begs caroline to get him away from
violet
unfortunately violet bangs on benjamin's
room
after she enters caroline immediately
looks for an excuse not to be caught
soon she tells luke that she is
suspicious of violet but sadly he
remains skeptical they travel to a gas
station that caroline previously noted
was lined with brick dust
she asks one of the proprietors who is a
blind woman about the conjure of
sacrifice
then she learns that the caster steals
the remaining years of life from the
victim
increasingly convinced of hudu's
authenticity she fears that violet will
soon cast the spell on benjamin back to
the house she discovers that violet is
unable to pass a line of brick dust laid
across one of the house's doorways
confirming her suspicions
she incapacitates violet and attempts to
escape the house with ben but unluckily
the front gate is chained shut then she
hides benjamin on the property and
manages to escape from that place
arriving at luke's office she finds out
that luke is violet's accomplice in fact
she is the target all along for the hutu
ritual not benjamin
from behind luke suddenly knocks her and
brings her back to the house
later she gets into a fight with violet
and violently pushes her down the stairs
breaking her legs in the process
with the use of brick dust she is able
to flee to the attic then calls 911 and
jill for help
in the attic she casts the spell which
she believes is a protective spell
meanwhile violet has caught up with her
and reveals that caroline actually
trapped herself inside a protective
circle making her impossible to get out
from the circle
violet pushes a full-length mirror at
her which reflects the original owner's
daughter ben violet and lastly mama
cecile
at the same time a recording of the
conjure of sacrifice plays and finally
the two switch bodies
violet who is revealed to be mama cecil
who had been occupying violet's body
through the ritual wakes up in
caroline's body after that she feeds
caroline who now is in violet's body a
potion that induces a stroke-like
paralytic state like ben
luke who is actually revealed as papa
justify arrives upstairs revealing that
mama cecile and papa justify have been
conducting the conjurer of sacrifice on
new people since their supposed deaths
that time they had swapped places with
the two children just before the
lynching because hudu is supposedly only
effective on those who believe in it
they had to wait for caroline to come to
believe in hudu through her own
investigation
a few moments later the emergency
services arrive and take caroline and
luke away trapped in the paralyzed dying
bodies of violet and ben
when jill arrives papa justified tells
her that the couple left the house to
caroline ensuring that he and cecile
will continue to occupy the house
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching